أظهرت دراسة جديدة أن التعرض للهواء الملوث
يشبه تدخين علبة
سجائر في اليوم
جاكلين هوارد كاتبة CNN
للصحة والعافية معنا الآن
، أعني نعم نحن نعلم أن
الهواء الملوث بشكل واضح سيء لنا مثل هذا السوء
مثل تدخين عبوة  دامي ، ما الضرر الذي يلحقه برئتينا ،
إنه أمر رائع للغاية
، لذا توجد هذه الدراسة الجديدة
التي وجدت أنه إذا
كنت تتنفس باستمرار هواءًا ملوثًا
على المدى الطويل ، فلنفترض أنك تعيش في مدينة بها
تلوث هواء لأكثر من 10 سنوات.  السنوات التي يمكن أن
تهيج وتلهب رئتيك
بطريقة مشابهة لتدخين السجائر ، لذا على
وجه التحديد يمكن أن يؤدي التهيج
إلى نوع من مرض الانسداد الرئوي المزمن يسمى انتفاخ الرئة وقد
عرفنا منذ فترة طويلة أن انتفاخ الرئة
مرتبط بتدخين السجائر ولكن
الآن يمكننا القول أنه مرتبط بـ
تلوث الهواء كذلك عندما نتحدث عن
تلوث الهواء ، فمن أين يأتي هو
أنه يأتي من المصانع التي تأتي
من حركة المرور ، لذلك كل ما سبق
، وعلى وجه التحديد عندما تنظر إلى
هذا  إنها قوية بشكل خاص
عندما تنظر على وجه التحديد إلى
الأوزون على مستوى الأرض ، لذا فإن الأوزون جزء من
الضباب الدخاني وهو ليس نادرًا حقًا كما
نعلم أنه شائع جدًا في الواقع
حتى أنه يقدر بشكل عام
حوالي 90 في المائة من الناس حول
العالم  تنفس الهواء الملوث ، لذلك من
المحتمل أنك قد تعيش في مدينة بها
تلوث للهواء ، يمكنك الإقلاع عن السجائر ،
ولا يمكنك الإقلاع عن الهواء ، ولا يمكننا
التوقف عن التنفس